League of Legends is a complicated
strategic online game and that's just
what Chris of sites likes he calls
himself and raided and has a contract
with professional gaming company SK
gaming he won't say what he makes but
his full-time job pays him well enough
although it's a tough one
kind of an hour skin does institution
octopus ouch don't usually it's between
8 and 12 hours on a usual day but ahead
of large tournaments it could be 14 or
even 16 hours those days you get minimal
sleep those only take breaks to eat by
the new quit suppose apart from that you
play and try to get better until you get
to know them to perfection Obama's like
um episode perfect zoo the game is
played in teams of five who have their
own coaches as well the business is
tough and players need to get the most
out of the few years they can muster the
skill and concentration to play at the
top in the US eSports have become widely
popular in Pennsylvania the Robert
Morris University even gives out
scholarships to the most talented
players they're celebrated like pop
stars 27 million people watched the 2014
League of Legends championship final
that's more than watch the baseball
world series final that year in Europe
the industry hopes to gain traction by
staging this year's show down the
finalists have survived a string of
qualifying rounds Christophe sites and
his team won many of them but didn't
make it to the final they'll be watching
along with millions of fans online when
two South Korean teams battle it out to
see who goes into the league of legends
Hall of Fame